là
bonsoir à toutes et tous et merci de
nous rejoindre sur tv 78 pour cette
retransmission en direct de la merise de
trappes de tif frappe un pro famille ni
cinquième édition déjà
c'est toute la famille déclic théâtre
qui va jouer ce soir sous vos yeux
ébahis de belles saynètes complètement
sortis de leur imaginaire je ne suis pas
seul vous le voyez chers
téléspectatrices hier téléspectateurs
j'ai su accompagner
je vais essayer de vous faire deviner
son nom elle porte le prénom d'abord de
la moitié de guillaume canet si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire et pour son
nom de famille et bien c'est le nom
d'une commode d'une certaine marque
suédoise
voilà un modèle de commode est-ce que
vous avez deviné marion bill est avec
nous ce soir
bonsoir marion soir j'ai bien vous vous
attendiez pas à 7h et vous voyez c'est
vrai pardon
eh ben c'est sûr mais en même temps la
moitié de guillaume canet 7 et guillaume
et billy et savent et guillaume gille is
kill c'est mon frère
ah bravo oui oui on sait que c'est très
rigolo quand vous parlez de marion
cotillard dans la caraïbe à samoëns
amoureux se passe à moitié bien sûr ça
va marion très bien et vous alors vous
allez maintenant oui ça va super bien
vous allez m'accompagner mais on va dire
vous êtes la spécialiste de
l'improvisation théâtrale
oui ce que vous pouvez vous présenter en
quelques mots à nos téléspectateurs à
nos téléspectatrices firmi bonsoir à
tous
écoutez j'ai quelques années d'un pro
derrière moi j'ai moi même participé au
spectacle nous allons voir ce soir et de
nombreux spectacles en france et dans la
francophonie et je me réjouis de voir
mes petits camarades sur scène car je
les connais tous assez bien répartis
allez c'est parti jusque-là enfants par
péter bruch et en laisser noyau le
public est au rendez vous ils sont plus
de 700 près de 800 m était complexe et
complet de chez contenait donc on est un
peu l'ambiance s'installe et on revient
vous voir dans quelques instants
musique de livres au top à base d'eau au
fond du trou et musique
de par le profit mais on chantait vous
allez voir c'est le talent d'olive que
tout le monde va reprendre à mon avis
encore en choeur dans quelques instants
c'est vraiment un fédérateur de foule
il sait faire santé publique
c'est pas le faire chanter au sens de
lui demander de l'argent même si ce soir
complètement tout vient lui a demandé de
la tourmente et il fallait payer
m
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voyez au bo
les gens savent pas ce qu'est ce que
vous êtes en mode hier marion que c'est
la profondeur des paroles de cette
chanson qui vous touche particulièrement
que l'universalité si nous les vues du
champ et de l'onomatopée qu'est-ce qui
va je suis très sensible aux gens qui
chantent tous ensemble d'accords en tout
cas ça marche pour l'instant ah oui
comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs en
général un olivier doyon gels ambiance
assurée c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
c'est formidable c'est formidable s'ils
arrivent à faire avec un délit
[Musique]
les hans applaudissant alors qu'ils ne
sont pas venus pour ça du tout c'est
formidable plus formidable nos alliés
chanteur plaisir des gens des comédiens
des comédiennes et il aboutit semaine
parmi les 60 dollars 6,6 soit 6 soit
qu'ils sont contents grande émulation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du moins pas comme ils se doivent
réclamer la maîtresse de cérémonie
elle est charmante elle est séduisant
pour la dame en jeu pour miss mélanie
lemoine la maîtresse de cérémonie en
fait une excellente comédienne
pour cette 5e sur l'autre homme
approfondie comme c'est fou de vous voir
aussi nombreux aussi nombreuses
quelle émotion c'est incroyable c'est ça
qui est bien avec la famille de l'impro
c'est qu'on est toujours content de la
retrouver elle
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire on va
passer une sacrée journée on vous a
attendu de pied ferme
on a un peu tourné en rond je vous le
cache pas c'est elle on l'attend été
longue
alors ben on s'est occupés comme on a pu
on a gonflé des ballons on a ciré nos
chaussures on a repassé d'abord un
pantalon bleu puis ensuite une robe
rouge vient ensuite une europe verte
on a sorti la belle vaisselle celle des
grands jours c'est le cas dans le buffet
du salon
et puis toutes les 100 minutes ont visé
c'est lars eller c'est là mais c'était
pas leur parce que c'était seulement 14
heures et les arrivées arrivent les
invités arrivent jamais avec autant
d'avancé
alors on a retiré nos chaussures
finalement on a mis une robe rouge je
sais pas si on aime la paix on a perdu
on n'a pas bien fait même si une fois
qu'on a eu fini tout ça une fois que
tout était briquet de fond en comble une
fois qu'on était prêts qu'on était chose
on avait chanté des chansons qu'on était
heureux et qu'on attendait plus que vous
une fois qu'on a eus fait tout ça on a
entendu un petit truc qui faisait comme
ça et là on était juste à côté là
dans les coulisses alors on s'est fait
un petit cadeau en pis on sait diva
c'est vrai les traditions de faire un
canal avant d'entrer en séries mais bon
match
j'attends que souhaiter bonne chance
mais qu'est-ce qu'on répond ah merde
rien
ça porte malheur de diamant
les autorités la ville rose à petit un
viol prestance en pétrole est bloqué les
femmes
un triomphe un tonnerre
d'applaudissements ouzou face à vis
d'une autre changement réglementaire et
c'est parti les douze joueuses et
joueurs qui entrent à l'instant dans la
patinoire pour le petit échauffement
les sags réglementaire software et 4
milliards est obligatoire et c'est une
pratique qui se fait de moins en moins
en maths improvisation parce que le
match d'impro évolué au fil des années
et il est vrai que selon les endroits
dans lesquels ont joué
les compagnies qui vont organiser les
gens qu'on a rencontrés on n'est plus
forcément ces cinq minutes
d'échauffement réglementaire ça fait
très longtemps du nord est a dit à l'ats
compromis en bazois la cua en fait c'est
ce que vous êtes en train de mentir
encore un milicien du match d'impro
voilà il ya des petits étirements ou
adulé galibert qui est très soudée
voilà en avant-scène évidemment pas
toujours les petits coquins qui se met
devant pour cabotiner faveur des publics
et virginie britten également qui fait
des étirements abdos joaillier qui est
en train de se rapprocher de leur coach
antoine rabbo
voilà leur coach leur leur fournit de la
matière à aller faire quelque chose en
exercice au général plutôt visuels pour
apporter au public quelque chose
d'intéressant
bon ce qui est bien avec l'échauffement
obligatoire réglementaire c'est que on
peut se mettre déjà dans onze ans alors
commencer tout de suite
à part une improvisation si oui si on a
un peu plus consultation avec le public
avec la scène avec ces gamins rapide
alors nous pensent qu'ils entendent
faire un petit tour au bel arbre joyet
toute sobriété abel théorie n'importe
qu'elle a l'air content
[Applaudissements]
mounir qui a un succès fou ah oui il
joue à la maison lui à domicile de
monnières dame
[Applaudissements]
un enfant de trappes et entrez vos
camarades de vue ce piment
[Musique]
alors ce soir marion va voir un match
entre deux belles équipes
ces composés de voir et de vos skis
on fait déclic théâtre en train de faire
des petits tapent qui ont participé à l'
on rappelle à nos téléspectateurs et le
téléspectateur pv qui captent et née en
donc ça fait si on s'y met compte sur
cet acte a fait 26 au 27 en 2020 oui
j'ai moi même j'ai par contre
voilà pour ces poursuites sauf ramener
la maison et je vais poser le jeu sera
offert les soustractions il dispose et
la recrue nathan 27 ans qui sont dans la
place et qui propose de l'improvisation
à saint quentin en yvelines et qu'ils
ont essaimé un peu partout en france et
qui sont même allés jusqu'aux à la terre
d'origine du match d'improvisation
théâtrale à savoir mais québec au québec
27 ans égalera exactement donc c'est
bien 27 dont 27,1 à la cepl si ça vous
donne envie de danser
parce que vous aimez bien vous quand
joueuses ouais les cinq minutes là ça
vous permet aussi de vous de vous
détendre un petit peu a montré c'est
chouette affaire m
[Musique]
en général voilà on fait d'accord où les
coaches des titres pop affaire il ya des
choses que j'aime plus ou moins fermés
il faut penser collectif et faire ce que
décide la majorité
la personne qui aura décidé
mais des fois on peut avoir à assumer
des choses on n'est pas très contents
l'accord par exemple a fait très mal à
l'aise loin de ses parents alors vous ne
savez pas danser mais vous êtes une
excellente chanteuse marion vous chantez
vous faites de la voix vous êtes
comedian spécialisés aussi en
improvisation théâtrale vous avez
d'autres talents cachés peut-être un
régulier oui plein la modestie
l'aménagement intérieur
les direction d'acteurs non respect d'un
passé pas tous ses biens alors chandail
le mènera line la société pas l'entraidé
de beaux atours et du coup là c'est la
présentation des deux équipes donc une
équipe qui va jouer en jaune et une
équipe qui va jouer en bleu les
hyperviseurs assure la présentation
chiadé et dany boon est pas sans
l'ignorer puisque vous n'êtes pas
j'imagine à votre première réunion de
famille trappe un pro famille il est
donc le temps pour moi d'accueillir un
personnage incontournable
il a l'humour d'un vieux tonton et la
sagesse d'une belle mère ce soir encore
il cachera sous une tignasse poivre et
sel une austérité coquine dont lui seul
a le secret je vous demande d'accueillir
comme il se doit
l'arbitré de cette rencontre nous aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non
quelle entrée ans
alors j'ai déjà noté de demander à la
maîtresse de cérémonie ce que voulait
dire une austérité coquine
voilà c est très métaphorique c'est très
imagine je pense
bonus un personnage incontournable de la
ville de trappes et de l'impro également
de ali akin qui a commencé l'impôt en
1939 mais bon est exact on a juste avant
la guerre il a plus un petit break après
il est toujours là avec l'eau aurélia
qui les joueurs et les joueuses de cette
rencontre
je vais commencer avec les coachs à
commencer par le coach de l'équipe des
bleus
un homme que j'ai souvent essayé de
demander en mariage et il n'est pas
impossible que je tente de relancer ce
soir parce que c'est un parent est gelée
couvrait bien ok les gars le bon bout ça
lui fait beaucoup de demandes
et oui c'est ça il est déjà parti
[Musique]
c'est vrai que je la demanderais bien
mariage également décidément tout le
monde veut se marier avec tout le monde
là qu'est ce qui explique que ce qui se
passe mal je sais pas on a les mêmes
goûts avec mélanie l'auboise peut-être à
melen viennent également pur produit de
déclic théâtre
mais mme boitard penaude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas bien trop belle l'occasion de jouer
souvent avec lui
nonchalant rôle arnaud joyet qu'on ne
présente plus arnaud joyet avec qui j'ai
eu un spectacle un duo
j'ai beau témoin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
115 kg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'ils sont en train de décrocher
dans la patinoire le joueur strobel et
le joueur je voyais ces pour des regards
en coin et retiennent un petit rictus
déjà ah ben ça promet un match avec des
draps en décrochage laurent base et qui
arrive au pas de course mais s'en sort
toujours des plus petits pas quand il
commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va
or avec un filet ce soir vous avez de la
chance
[Musique]
saisie la partie
[Applaudissements]
quel succès pour mounir danemark est
impressionnant de radio
et oui ils jouent à domicile
ça doit lui mettre la pression
il y a
un grand coeur artistes numéro 40 de
l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de plus elle devient la liste
et effectivement une jeune mariée
alexandra feignait quel sens et quelle
chanceuse où il fait toujours pas mariée
maman
et c'est maintenant l'heure de limoux
professionnel impro famille qui
l'intégralité de ce casting a été
annoncé comme il se doit
il est le moment de secouer vos cheveux
pour enlever effectivement vos confettis
n'hésitez pas ta pour ceux qui ont des
cheveux bien entendu je vais vous
demander et l'heure cet hymne moi j'y
suis particulièrement fier parce que
quand j'ai rencontré lancera pour
écouter avec toutes les championnats de
france juniors et 16 ans mais possible
et j'ai joué un an contre qui fit
rapidement le match avant d'être
j'entends dans cette tribune se priver
j'ai moins 25 ans les thés junior le
trap
[Applaudissements]
on va bien s'amuser bien ça faisait mon
gobelet la confiture
non
[Applaudissements]
dray
et voilà donc lyn des juniors de trappe
alors l'équipe des juniors des trappes
c'est l'équipe des 15 19 ans 2 déclic
théâtre voilà c'est un peu l'équipe
d'excellence un port pour la jeunesse et
à d'autres équipes qui sont adultes mais
voilà vraiment les 15 19 ans et ceux qui
en europe sont arrivés au bout d'un
petit cheminement qui ont commencé pour
certains au collège pour d'autres chez
les benjamins et qui arrive que les
d'une heure de drap
donc on a cet article avait un petit
hommage tout c'est la famille et ils ont
tous plus ou moins participé à cette
équipe des juniors
si monsieur larbitre cible trois fautes
à une des équipes
elle cédera un point à l'autre équipe
c'est la règle c'est la règle du jeu
mais monsieur l'arbitré nous regarde
avec un oeil ou ces jeunes et donc lui
laisser la parole
bon match à tous ces doutes
merci
[Applaudissements]
ça commence fort il n'est pas très aisé
mais cet arbitre un premier temps ils
ont joué regarder l'eau provoquent les
publics
[Musique]
monsieur ou madame rien bonsoir à tous
bienvenue ici à la mairie jusqu'à quatre
ou cinq travaux nature improvisation je
resterai pour toi si vous restez
courtois
quelle ambiance
bien vous avez décidé je ne ferai pas
pour toi
au moins ça coûtera cher capitaine âme
c'est vous captez demandé ce mois oui
c'est moi seul coup pourquoi de sa maman
d'autres équipes mais très vite elle
seule vous pouvez décemment votre équipe
les premiers habitations
se joue avec les arbitres
attention elle peut sanctionner
le répète tout seul improvisation mixte
qui aura pour thème les sucrés nombre de
joueurs illimité catégorie libre durée
de l'improvisation 3 et non pas les
est ce que comme moi vous avez entendu
les plus loin déploie sucre et du thé à
la framboise que c'était l'été je les
entendais qu'il a vraiment faire et les
ou l'autre mais je pense de ce fait les
tgv soit il a une diction exceptionnels
soit il a eu un petit bug
jusque là les quelques alors on était
scrutée et congelés moi je partirai dans
des fruits de l'exotisme
déjà pas mal des fruits l'exotisme et
après faudra prouver les d'histoire avec
tout ça on était une équipe étoile du
thé à la menthe
parce qu'ils vont proposer c'est parti
merci merci beaucoup
bonjour mais je pense que tous les tous
les après midis chez la fois passé sur
cette place qu'elle a voulu que tous les
après midi me dégonfle masse eskimos
ce soit à nice et au soir chouchou
baigner aller s'il vous plaît je suis
c'est joli il faut que je paye mes
études auxquelles s y penser je pense à
coup je joue de nous avait mal à la
mâchoire baptiste je tenais à dire que
je vous ai observé je vous ai observés
sur cette plage de perpignan et j'ai
observé nos empreintes sur votre panneau
ou sur le sable et ça m'a plu baptiste
voulait dire que moi je vous plais n'a
plus tellement fait moi alors j'ai séché
relire ici c'est parce qu'elle cherchait
l'amour armes à la mer
tut tut tut tut tut tut sur moi
j'ai ça en moi quelque chose qui compte
je ne sais pas ça m'arrive je viens à 18
ans je suis jeune
[Applaudissements]
m
vous animez tard il suffit de lui faire
du bouche à tous
[Applaudissements]
je sors malsaucy
vous perdez vous à mousson
reda ok très bien pas manger voilà voilà
que c'était shamir complètement dans une
tempête
je ne sais pas qui choisir on a souvent
réussi la perf union je travaille sur
mon tir j'ai choisi je crois qu'ils sont
en train de se choisir de recevoir
seulement envers connaissent vous invite
encore une fois j'arrive trop tard
[Applaudissements]
aux analyses tu vas finir sa vie celle
venue ici pour payer vos études oui je
voulais être vétérinaire mais j'ai
abandonné je vais te saigner
ok c'est très bien
c'est bien beau mais c'est dans vos
études les portes ouvertes
c'est une autre chose six sauveteurs
humoriste le soir puis par exemple je
suis baigné ne fait pas attention à ça
fait facilement fait comme si je n'étais
pas là j'ai l'habitude avec ma mère
j'ai pas compris je crois qu'il ya
la balle alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette première ça fait
c'est très fluide et ça fait super jo de
vous dire que tu vas t'y mets sont
ralentis et qui va chercher le
concurrent wyeth est fulgurante
en avril on sent que c'est encore un
petit peu rouillé ya des petits blancs
c'est pas parce que vous êtes en train
de vous dire est ce que vous avez écouté
di resta respect de cette catégorie que
les têtes us us que les têtes et sucrés
pour vous oui le thème par dire oui on
voit des glaces à mette à perpignan
c'est du sud magnifique
attention aucune consigne est seulement
et après chaque improvisation
j'attendrai mon signal votre bonne s'il
vous plaît ça c'était beau le jeune âge
et ce sont les jaunes avec la belle
prestation 2 milliards d'années qui
ouvre ton coeur tellement c'est normal
qui est récompensée par ce vote du
public qui a beaucoup donné
donc ça fait 1 pour les jaunes 0 pour
les bleus
alors ce qui est intéressant avec le
petit meneur d'hommes c'est qu'il a
commencé mais en 2001 l'improvisation au
collège et vous savez pourquoi il a fait
ça devenait trop et pas autre chose
parce que ça vers la poussée justement à
faire de l'impro parce que le foot
c'était payant le ont été payants et
l'impro c'est et gratuit mais m et du
queens inscrit il nous a autorisé à lire
improvisation mixte qui ont rapporté
mardi des larmes en acier de là
siègent donc ne vouloir imiter catégorie
libre tulle et de cette improvisation
5,8 cinq minutes
des larmes en acier
catégorie libre il me semble j'ai pas
entendu si on avait donné un autre
catégorie
et pour terminer sur mon père d'adam
leur lui il a commencé du coup en 2001
au collège louis et il a fait presque
toutes les catégories avec les terres
qu'il ya une équipe de benjamins il
apparaît qu'il a fait les cadets ensuite
les juniors et 15 19
et puis maintenant il est aux épices
donc c'est l'équipe adulte le déclic
terme de rancennes way de grand chelem
et puis l'étape il a été il a l'appui
d'un spectacle intéressant qui s'appelle
hot fix young boys avait déjà des films
improvisé ouais on voit là ils prennent
des fuites mais les triture ils étaient
tournées puis qui des jours opnet
improvisation de rendre publique
cometti des trois bornes à paris allez
la deuxième part nous rejoignent et se
prépare ainsi que les rangs des deux
anciennes un très bon camarade à moi
bonjour
bonjour est repoussant 40
j'ai l'impression que tu est frappé
d'une mélancolie comme moi est ce que je
me trompe je suis en plein de mélancolie
voici à 240 je ne suis que souffrance
d'acier moi aussi un peu même si tu
m'appelles m nous sommes touchés par la
mélancolie des cyborgs gesca oui tu as
recharger la batterie ce matin oui oui
je la retrouve tout seul mais même si
c'est déconseillé mais comme ça le matin
je suis en pleine forme en pleine
possession de mes moyens mais je sens
mon coeur lourd comme du tungstène bon
sens si quelque chose a confié
d'ailleurs 240 peut-être es-tu touchés
par le même mal alors que nous nous
apprêtons à caen de la planète astoria g
et gerden par mme amal incroyable mais
de quel tiff mettre les sentiments
je crois que je suis pourvu de
sentiments humains
mais moi aussi m depuis le début je suis
pour beat sentiments j'ai aimé que je
suis né j'ai aimé ma mère qui d'ailleurs
est en terre puisque c'était à l'homme
je te propose que nous avions tous les
deux ans la planète à ce que rien et que
nous cherchions l'amour mais youpi
quelle bonne idée
décidément cet élan collectif latin est
vraiment profonde oui je les syndromes
de youppi est généralement à mort et si
je ne suis pas bien que te dire de plus
jamie lee sur la planète est rien pour
visionner peur pensant avoir que je
déambule sur cette planète avec toi il
ya 140 jeunes desquels notre destin est
brouillée par ses sentiments abscons et
néanmoins bajeux par le train il ya
quelque chose que tu n'as pas vu mon
dieu je vous avais l'air 240
oui je ressens quelque chose de
dangereux comme nous sommes pourvus de
sentiments humains j'ai l'impression que
aussi nous y allons être pourvus du
péché clic capital de landi en trop mou
de la jalousie
je suis moi même pétri de stress
r 240 je ne ferai pas que mon amour
naissant pour cette créature que tu dois
partager entendre notre amitié résident
les chouchous il a fallu apprendre à
vous calmer un petit peu et nous ne
crions nombreux voter à ces histoires
d'amour mach année dernière il ya comme
zemmour donné par mm aussi non ça va ça
te trouvais trop de larmes s'il te plaît
mais dans ma prise du sentiment
attention court circuit patrick féminin
court-circuit batterie faiblit au nom au
nom je t'aime
maintenant j'ai vu là bien tranquille vu
aucun sentiment je suis encore pro jean
comme devant
alors 940 du ça que je suis partageur
d'habitude il faut que tu te branche à -
si tu veux partager le sentiment
j'éprouve en plus il faut partager dans
les étagères et là franchement je me
révolte
tu voudrais pas de contrat pour ça
suffit il y en a marre il en a ras le
pompon
non c'est vrai moi va tenir
je crois que c'est leur donner 30
numérique pour communier mais attention
chaque succès du film le décor
jouissance jouissent aux grossesses ont
une grossesse en route la garde du chien
je jure je vous ai gym élèves c'est
gémellaires à chacun sa m 800 à 900 2
920 avec la crosse s'assumer l'air si
j'ai bien vécu les bien sûr quel bonheur
de se sentir maire de montchanin
cette seconde catégorie 3 secondes
le seconde au décollage imminent
voilà pour cette belle improvisation et
passionné capable de poser une histoire
de partir dans un univers de science
fiction
le joueur doit y est fidèle à son style
qui explique beaucoup de mots sans
aucune émotion seulement 7
écoutez c'est bien c'est bien je mets
mais l'aja pour le moment on n'a pas de
sutton qu'un petit truc l'égalisation
passait très bien
c'est très cossu c'est moi pour
apprendre à regarder
explication de cette très simple des
règles très précises en match
d'improvisation appartements et un
espace de jeu claires et déterminées par
cette patinoire qui est que dès qu'on
participe au jeu dès qu'on prend la
parole dans le jeu il faut être d'une
manière ou d'une autre en contact avec
cette patinoire en vous et vos deux
rôles coeur qui ici présent n'a pas été
en contact a pris un micro déjà on peut
mettre des lits mais là dessus jc à
couper dans la patinoire
elle n'était pas en avant
[Applaudissements]
c'est une vieille règle de la fin des
années 60 ministres jo a évolué depuis
dans le jeu a évolué mais moi non
[Rires]
[Musique]
donc la revente de leurs bases et c'est
à dire pour moi de jouer a évolué parce
que effectivement c'est une des règles
initiales c'est ça
une des règles initiales du match
d'impro comme il a été créé par des
québécois dans les années 70 70 66 oui
tout à fait sûrs et liquides et a forcé
un batteur
oui
[Applaudissements]
un regard 12 et c'est l'égalisation de
semble-t-il pour l'équipe des bleus
partout donc le r 220
a réussi son coup et alors parlez moi un
peu de ce losc
arnaud joyet là parce que y'a peut-être
autre chose à écouter
c'est un vieux camarade improvisateurs
avec qui on a dit beaucoup sur scène et
en dehors de la tène et on a créé un
très joli spectacle tous les deux qu'il
a mise à sion comparer qui aura pour
thème au plus loin de nos foyers
au plus loin de nos foyers
on connaît
nombre de joueurs est limité catégorie
comptait à la manière d'une légende
demain durée de cette improvisation 2
minutes et 30 sont toujours talonnés
toyer après vous leur parlerez de
joaillier après marion la raconte plus
loin de nos foyers avec une contes et
légendes de marins sont comptés à soual
et bien
une organisation après de te le thème
colle avec avec la catégorie ya des
marins voir des marins sur un bateau au
foyer ils vont voyager
voilà vous aller quelque part pour leur
manquait ouais l'été s'annonce pas si
des sirènes peut-être
des bateaux pirates bon on va voir des
possibles parce que justement vous dire
que tout est possible mais peut-être que
sur la première comparez surtout de 7
après 2006 très court 1 pour une relance
l'opep alors qu'ils soient très content
y est
qu'ils sachent compris en passe par un
conte un début voilà donc ramassé une
courage des anciens
[Musique]
et bien futurs marins vous preniez mais
il faut bien que je me compte l'histoire
l'épaule janeiro tony hawk a mis tout ce
qui avait de plus normal il débouchés
aux ménages mais sa femme tooba très
malade fallu malo qu'elle cherchait
l'aqdr que les sponsors les gays mais la
dispute était saoul et du marteau
jeannot je suis tombé malade s'assurer
qu'elles collectent j'te ramènerait
cette algue
et le prix talent son petit avion et un
porte à son perroquet j'ai été toujours
de bon conseil
desmidt a vogué sur les sept mers des
océans 1 cherche l'affectif alors mon
coco à ce qui était beau j'ai bien vu
c'est fait content de t'avoir avec moi
tout seul sans personne âgée chez la
dame aime bien amis en parlent et nous
étions 11 au mois d'août et au mois
d'août la tempête jean sur les maires du
lot alors en pleine tempête
ils ne le seraient plus qu'à traverser
la tempête
à hong kong macao
prenez sur les lieux de sa mort j'arrive
je suis aussi
après cette fois
tu tombes nos prières
[Applaudissements]
la sirène voulait la tuer dans son piège
au moment où il était le préfet le plus
susceptible de craquer à ses charmes
il se souvint alors des dernières
paroles de sa femme avant de partir je
suis tombé malade tu peux aller chercher
cet homme gagne tu m'as volé du bosphore
[Applaudissements]
mais non c'était pas ça c'est moi les
roues à rayons qui arrêté c'est alors
que monsieur les marins alors de prendre
la mer mais ce téléphone au chant des
sirènes et souvenez-vous quel soldat
monde puisque c'est difficile il faut la
préparer la chute un peu simple ben on
est rentrés par sabine on la trouvait en
picardie pour la trouver voilà qui est
l'assassin de marcher dessus
allez les jaunes et fabien strobel pour
sa première apparition
je suis un vieux mas cette taverne en
histoire n'est pas extraordinaire
il y a quelques années de cela nous
étions deux sur ce bateau la traviata
nous tournions traits du la grande
rivière
c'est un morceau de merde qui en hongrie
viennent nous étions là pour pêcher
comme d'habitude lorsqu'un coup de vent
des matin le bateau
le mas été arrachés et le 29 hockey au
gré non pas du genre puisqu'il n'y avait
plus de voiles mais du courant pendant
plusieurs jours nous étions
seul mais comme et mat
j'ai récupéré honnart montent sur leur
honda mon cas sur un rondin et des
stupides certes petit mais c'est sans
ligne une idée quand même
l'équpe affronter visage j'avais les
yeux rougis marriott
mais on se sent vivant non on est
vivement sa fille voulait mais on n'y
fit et wii c'est vers cette histoire
mais pas extraordinaire et elle est
triste car je viens vous la conter seul
saint-andré donc que cette bûche est
nous étions 2
je sens que je glisse jeu j'ai pu voir
par exemple je sens de l'église et des
cours de survie en moi à toi je te
laisse rester là je tant pis
cette budget ne portait plus qu'une
personne raccourci ti punch pour vous
[Musique]
moi ce qui est logique puisque si
ç'avait été l'autre personne je n'aurais
pas pu raconter cette histoire à partir
dans une mer pour régler un problème
avec sa mère tout moncomble ce 2 mai dès
la 10 mois qui me fait dévorer par elle
dans ses veines j'ai dit ça c'est moi
mais on va faire mais il se relève et
nice et votre histoire j'ai beaucoup de
ménage à faire très bien je vais rentrer
chez moi avec mon travail chute mairie
de foix bien ce projet qui a assuré une
construction tout au long de cette
histoire kenya volcker qui vient
remplacer un autre contexte bien
surprendre comté et vous rendez un cadre
différent qui vient apporter une touche
timo et là encore une faute qui a été
sifflé par la suite de la rencontre
crois que c'est contre l'équipe des
bleus c'est vrai c'est trop de trucs en
très peu de temps c'est ce que vous
dites et c'est exactement le problème de
cette appréciation cap tête
les choses arrivent dans un pas dans un
désordre et dans un rythme assez
difficile à suivre
un volet des comédiens qui vont parler
en même temps dit retard de jeu c'est
pas un ensemble à se repaître de la
confusion ou du monde des coûts dans
cette opposition mais je me devais de
citer quelque chose parce que excusez
moi elle n'était pas parfaitement
invisible pour le cuir chaleur alors
voici sur une étude pour la pub ici
parce qu'il s'agit de le multaq eu
beaucoup plus salée
et ne pas me l'emploi c'est petit jeu de
questions réponses du capitaine et de
l'arbitré c'est vraiment toujours
quelque chose qui vient ici bien
apporter si une impôts a été un petit
peu molle un bon coup de peps c'est un
peu risqué comme un puisque on rappelle
que quand un joueur à deux fautes
personnelles s'il tombe vraiment sur un
arbitre un peu méchant et c'est
l'exclusion définitive
est ce qu'on peut faire dans cette
équipe là qui est un super c'est une
faute
c'est une faute équipe effectivement
mais comme la joueuse verger des great
elle l'a ramené un petit peu bâtard
capitaine alors oui à l'idée qu'elle
pourrait se faire cueillir et ce sont
les bleus qui ont marqué bizarrement la
promise à sur la boîte bien construite a
remporté les faveurs du public
certainement à cause de cette joute
capitaine
harry oui parce qu'on va chercher les
points jusque dans les écarts sont de
froch a dit donc à improvisation mixte
qui aura pour thème mon frère mon
frangin nous vous de jouer
l'illimité catégorie libre durée de
cette improvisation une minute et trente
secondes
j'ai bien en 38 minutes à une minute pas
plus difficile de faire des
improvisations google alors est-ce qu'on
peut terminer notre aventure sur arnaud
joyet oui c'est huit minutes prend pour
qui bien j'avais bien l'entendre c'est
lumineux trois ans par le joaillier cas
centre nc oui qu'est ce que vous me
disiez tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que je vous disais dans le
dans un café improvisation il a créé
avec sa petite bande avec la simon
associés
tu dit ian walker
et d'autres camarades fuite un nouveau
match d'impro une nouvelle forme
d'improvisation sa joueur très très
actif en hauteur un acteur fort match
avec un mois ben moi si chamakh n'a pas
trouvé monsieur mac et sian mais quand
on a mis ça moi c'est moi frêche
proximus que la météo est quoi une
voiture ben moi j'ai demandé levant
et j'aime entêté zhu à barry john je
serais vraiment en tant que n'existent
plus
moi j'ai demandé sa main h et k rod
effet d'acheter rien fait depuis des
années
[Musique]
je n'ai pas du sang
speed debout voilà tel salon cappone -
baca accroupi jan
c'est ça que j'avais vraiment quoi on
s'est ainsi fait la fête en ce seul
foyer pour mes fils est un foyer tout
coup allez
c'est pas paris passé on dit au les
frangins en tant que soeur je souffre
d'un poignet jouer pleinement ses titres
aux gens et c'est trop masculin je
souffre beaucoup de bars mais c'était
bien une minute trente minutes 31 12 x
c'est un peu punk chili on a eu
l'énergie alors on a senti la joueuse
galibert j'aime être sur le même
registre que la joueuse volcker et cette
étude escalade de qui aura le dernier
mot
cette intervention de monsieur m'a dit
qui est un homme fait des listes
écoutez c'est intéressant et intérêts en
tout cas ça fait 3 pour les bleus et un
pour les jaunes donc voilà on va dire
que c'est le point du break pour le
moment on regardait arnaud joyet avec
quel entrain il est en train de suivre
ses camarades sur sept ans
les bandes qu'on appelle le banc quand
on fait tous ensemble à une chorégraphie
comme ça c'est généralement avec la
vieille version du match et est libre et
on doit faire un banc c'est ce qu'on
voulait dire qu'on fait le match d'impro
à l'ancienne oui oui d'accord bon on
respecte les fondamentaux improvisation
mixte qui aura pour thème ce que ta mère
nous a lui fait nombre de joueurs il
l'imité catégorie bibliothèque de
l'improvisation 4 jamais entendu parler
de cette catégorie
bibliothèque alors larbitre va expliquer
donner les joueurs de chaque équipe vont
avoir en leur possession un livre la
ville haute et qu'ils aient leurs
improvisations devra donc commencé avec
les dialogues inscrit sur ce livre est
ce que tu as envie que je pus ceux
autorisés à
il s'agit
voilà il s'agirait je l'avais noté
quelques pas de la salle vis de l'acte
iii du malade imaginaire de partir sur
quelque chose très théâtral personnage
de toi
et du coup faudra respecter vraiment la
catégorie également de vocabulaire et
tous sont d'accord dwan était habillé en
médecins et bien s'enquérir du malade
imaginaire
monsieur je vous demande pardon
[Musique]
mais justement et demandé pardon ça
tombe égal mais c'est très bien demander
parle franchement dans les toilettes
le malade imaginaire acte iii scène dise
ce que ta mère nous a laissé messieurs
je vous demande pardon de tout mon coeur
soleil tu admires ap
vous ne trouvez pas mauvais s'il vous
plaît la curiosité que j'ai eue de voir
un illustre malades comme vous êtes et
votre réputation qui s'étend partout
peut excuser la liberté que j'ai prise
monsieur je suis votre serviteur je vois
monsieur que vous me regarder fixement
quel âge
croyez vous bien que j'aie au je crois
que tout au plus vous pouvez avoir 26 ou
j'en ai bien trouver un revendeur oui
vous voyez à nice et des secrets de mona
de me conserver ainsi frais et vigoureux
pas ma foi vrai impôt 5 milliard pour 90
ans
je suis médecin passagers qui fait de
villes en villes de province en province
deux royaumes au royaume pour chercher
dit lustres matière à ma capacité pour
trouver des malades digne de m'occuper
capable d'exercer les grands et bons
secret que j'ai trouvé dans la médecine
est bien pour moi y est forte est ce que
vous ayez choisi la place ici car je
suis moi zain un malade comme on en a
jamais connu et pas mal comme on n'a
jamais trouvé ni je vois le mal que je
n'ai jamais connu enfoncé et j'espère
quand je vous regarde vous avez pas tout
vous oui j'ai peur à mes peurs du podium
du père de j'aurais peur de vieillir à
votre âge que moi j'avais quand j'avais
votre âge avant remet au père de la mort
approche et quincy deux mois fait je met
ainsi en hausse des billets là dedans
mais je me sens déjà bien que vous dites
je meurs déjà je sens je vais mourir au
maire mais santé plein air alors mais
vous êtes père sympa fossoyeur
c'est daniel chopin alors chris et moi
je vous donnerai tout haut ce que on
peut léguer mes parents aient lieu mais
j'ai tout ce qu'il faut pour payer ma
vais vomir présent nié trésor au moins
ont donné mon endroit ça me suffira au
sol se ferra l'éternité un imprimeur
siens je veux montrer notre amour
bien que de vous la portez ça me fend le
coeur je n'arrive pas de la porte
j'ai la pause ici j'ai cru défaillir on
le sait qu'elle est lourde chape et
moi-même l'apprend voilà à maranello sur
toi bah oui tu croiras je me tâte et où
je ne souhaiterais pas de votre groupe
moi j'espère bien menacé d'un mois dans
l'année
bagdad est tombée ce matin et malgré mon
gaillard un chemin pour que c'est
pleinement
je fais la teinte est là alors on va y
aller bien l'hymne ans de cela on aura
des conséquences donnez moi oui mais là
je sens que dans cette course il y as
mal à penser possession de votre
jeunesse éternelle
vous saurez tout sur ma note bien sûr on
se sent que mon âme je vis de pièce par
pièce
je sentais fanni est vite nous n'avons
trouve toujours bon mais fois chercher
dans les tiroirs au vote on peut penser
l'ivoirien restait parfois se cache ou
une armoire aux gars c'était le collier
que ma mère m'a légué en morin pensez
vous que cela cela votre collier rami le
chaland sont là que je pourrais porter
un coup ci c'est vrai mais perd dans le
même madame
vous avez été marion j'avais piqué du
nez
ben oui je me regardais les endormir et
cette catégorie faut dire que très
difficilement de son père soit de text
ecm ont goûté ils sont bien battus et
ils n'auraient pas respecté le vôtre jeu
c'était bien mais j'en lexical cette
exigence et des comédiens gueule
aguerris qui ont fait le travail mais
c'était pas facile et ça fait quand même
3 à 2 avec la belle prestation danel
thibout dubois elle et les formations
classiques des 84 sélections s'est
passionné pour quelqu'un de très entière
de très investi dans une cabine et du
coup ça sans dents dans son jeu mais
elle était dans le bol hier le câble a
évoqué l examen écrit jamais à côté en
fait à ma moitié
après tu es folle et toi tu rapportes m
un jour sans finale nombreux joueurs et
illimité catégorie libre durée des fins
d'information
trois mille ans alors juste
juste un jour sans quelque chose mais
oui un jour son fils à la baie du coup
ces foires été très bon on verra en tout
cas y'a un jour de la tv ou le soir ça
ce péché en lumière la nôtre aussi
baissé et c'était très agréable c e
n'est pas parce que oui si ça se
défoulent je vais avoir mal à la tête
très fort dans cinq minutes qu'est ce
que vous voulez boire de l'eau c'est
devant moi c'est comme une mer sans eau
c'est comme une rivière sans cailloux je
crois que c'est logicien d'avoir une
malade imaginaire
non c'était même avant le malade
imaginaire je vais tenir mais en fait
cela devait changer
qu'est ce que je vous propose les yeux
fermés des yeux voilà ça passe à travers
les pots cassés
ad c'est reparti ici pour cette
improvisation comparez donc le petit
palais de l'arbitré pour mon compte
voilà deux qui commence et qui va
demander comment il va commencer
[Musique]
décidément que tu pourras générosité
nouvelle générosité par là c'est ce
qu'ont dû aller l'équipe des jaunes qui
va commencer coup
[Musique]
[Rires]
partant d'un mauvais lancer de voter
[Applaudissements]
c'est horrible sur des pilotes seulement
que marie elle retourne leur évolution
[Applaudissements]
je vais courir jusqu'à l'église je vais
aller voir le curé pour qu'ils jurent
leurs grands dieux que le site c'est
parti
j'aurais pu te serais peut-être pas dû
dire que cette laiterie qui a tenté de
courir si le curry de morceler le voir
médiathèque
[Applaudissements]
je suis parti
les vétérans le message apaisant de me
donner j'ai perdu mon côté je me
cherchais dans le coup buts et peut-être
buts et non non capitaliste et états
unis tiers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce sera physique vous amuser la demande
s'est déversée au soccer mais un jour
avec sein de beaucoup d'actions à venir
autour de vente situation est sûre elle
n'y est pas alors de cigales kenya nous
sommes allés la deuxième après
[Applaudissements]
c'est tellement bizarre je comprends pas
vous l'avez dit vous l'avez dit
vous nous l'aviez dit mais moi je n'ai
pas cru une seconde je ne pensais pas
que c'était possible
on ne pensait pas que c'était possible
je ne pensais pas que c'était possible
et bien commun jours vous apprendrez à
m'écouter
tout sera possible à la question je
m'étais renseigné j'ai lu beaucoup de
livres j'ai regardé des films dans et
non ce n'était pas possible eh bien
sachez bien la différence entre la
réalité et les mon dieu il semblerait
que ce soit possible
[Applaudissements]
de l'eau du ciel à aix en provence
et oui voilà pourquoi elles ne vont pas
se moquer des gens du nord vont retenir
quoi on peut croire dans le monde alors
s'il peut ici
un regard hargneux j'ai passé sa marque
et vip l'honneur c'est un déluge
regardez ce qui m'arrive j'ai les
cheveux mouillés approche donc ma propre
fait nous toucher c'est de l'eau qui
tombe du ciel mon âge c'est un us open
je sais ce n'est pas croyable et de ne
jamais me tient presque vides etc
étaient pleins sans rien demander
oui est ce qu'il est bon comme un patin
à glace
madame de les 500 députés qui siègent
entre eux rappelle deux phénomènes un
phénomène de plus de toit depuis ses
locaux
j'ai l'impression que même le monde
mais vous savez comme dans les bains
vous inquiétez pas vous mentir et
regardez là vraiment pas qu'un sas aux
abords des noeuds papillon vous voyez
messieurs le choc que l'ua mais ses
prises n'arrive à envier au mondial et
aux 37 38 et depuis 10 minutes déjà
delplanque enfants comment ma défaite
je roule à midi
[Applaudissements]
à écouter c'est presque rien n'avait
jamais souri à 10 par an et est parti
elle a conclu elle a bien conclu
c'est le point qui va aller à l'équipe
des jaunes
c'est effectivement une égalisation ça
fait donc trois pour les jaune et bleu
égalité parfaite alors judée galibert la
part des deux petites julie galibert
avis galibert on s'est rencontré
par l'intermédiaire de déclic théâtre
poursuit arrivée à paris moi maintenant
marc gêné par camara qui est fait de
l'improvisation c'est le junior a grandi
et c'est comme comparer trappe et de
sony ouais bien pour thème les escaliers
de la tour de pise nombre de joueurs est
limité mais nation 45
elle va dire t'as texte quoi c'est pas
vrai
je vais vraiment me plaindre au niveau
tactique si je comprends bien
et oui oui c'est très content car on se
met donc j'étais junior à marcq en
baroeul jmj j'ai commencé à prendre
l'information aux terres c'est que marcq
en baroeul et pour marquer quand même
que j'ai dis pas recommencer millions
marquant par elle
c'est ça je vais commencer la prod à
paris et pourquoi dire ça oui
exemple j'ai fait des quintettes avec
déclic j'ai rencontré julie ils font
abondamment
et vous
tout ça a dû être une sacrée rencontre
c'était sacré numéro ses petits
justement ces êtres qui commençait à 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
45 secondes c'est très difficile de
raconter nba
mais techniquement c'est possible oui
petite fille tendance a commencé avant
un pic tendance a commencé avant
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez compris cette
histoire je crois que le but de cette
improvisation ce qu'ils ne font pas le
comprendre l'histoire mais de mars y ait
dans la tour de pise de monter des
escaliers et de les descendre un accord
était un peu le but des deux histoires
je claque
et d'ailleurs cette histoire de souder
galibert et de vidéos mézières qui a
remporté les suffrages du public
ça fait donc quatre à trois le matin
marqués c'est très serré oui
et comme hier l'ambiance doucy également
à oui là à la députée avait besoin
qui veut des bleus
la tête une dernière a promise à sion de
l'être moi qu'est ce que vous pensez du
match aller on va
alors est-ce que je suis mal commencé en
sept mois ce qui est beaucoup trop en
faire et qui va falloir qu'ils se
trouvent sur une belle grande mixte où
ils auront le temps de jouer et de
s'amuser comme ils commencent à le faire
de plus en plus dans leur vin pour
différencier pour que ça prenne tous
ensemble à que tous les comédiens
s'éclate dans une impro commune
c'est la mi-temps vous l'aurez remarqué
marion et oui on va aller boire un petit
café volant voilà on va aller faire un
petit oui je vais chercher mes lunettes
de ce que j'ai pu habiter des
projecteurs sur la retraite
au total et pourtant vous avez
l'habitude d'être sous le feu des
projecteurs
allez on se rejoint dans quelques
minutes pour la seconde mi temps
attention car pour les bleus 3 pour les
jaunes match très serré a tout de suite
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
wahou
où
à la
la pole man se repose on dit des choses
on voit la vie